hello everyone and welcome back to the
world's championship match between Yani
polishi and dingler and this is the
second game of the Rapids first game
ended in a draw and now Nepal will try
his best with the white pieces the uh to
to grab a full point and gain a lead in
the match so let's check it out Nepal
with the white pieces opens with E4 we
have E5 binding so nothing really
changing in the rapid time form at
Knight F3 Knight to C6 uh and the bishop
to B5 again Dory Lopez is on the board
and Ponte A6 dingos for morphe's defense
and will we see a marshall let's see
what was on the board Bishop A4 Knight
to F6 castles Bishop to E7 and nepo of
course declines it with Pawn to D3 or
rather avoids it uh with Pawn to B5
Bishop to B3 and the D6 with Pawn to A4
at Bishop to D7 and now Pawn to H3 so
still all very standard stuff here
castles and Bishop to E3 with Knight A5
going after the bishop Bishop to A2 and
now B captures an A4 and this is all a
very very known stuff it's been played
by top Grand Masters such as elter
Safari and gatacom scheme although with
white and here after Bishop to D2
interestingly we have a completely new
game so here the Knight is attacked the
I think is for the moment up upon but
it's a double a pawn and he will get the
semi-open v file for his Rook so what is
uh nepo's idea here well he will have
the more active Bishops and he will
probably pick up one of the pawns uh
very quickly so here Knight back to C6
by ding Knight to C6 going after the
pawn and The Rook the B8 putting the
Rook on the nice semi-open B file and
the nipple just takes the A4 pawn and
defends his B2 pawn and now comes Knight
to D4 and Bishop to C4 uh just going
after that um A6 pawn and Here pawn to
C6 a very interesting Try by ding the
point is that if you go for something
like a bishop to B5 which is a move
that's kind of expected then let's say
B3 and yes you can capture here B
captures B captures but now
uh nothing is really happening here you
still have the A6 spawn okay maybe later
on you can push it but uh you know from
experience you know that that's not very
likely so C6 is a much better try
especially for a a rapid game uh and not
Knight captures on the for the problem
with capturing now on A6 is that once
Rook comes to A8 and attacks the bishop
you will go back and now D5 comes and
now you have to you know suffer uh just
Bishop to B3 for example to to defend
the the Knight on A4 now let's say
Knight captures B captures and you get
this position where a pawn structure is
ruined you have an isolated D Pawn you
have a isolated Double B Pawn so not not
the greatest and the ding keeps the
bishop pair so instead after C6 we have
this Knight characters on D4 move by
nipple e captures and Bishop to F4 move
now preparing Pawn to E5 uh with Bishop
to E6 uh going after the bishop on C4
even though there was discussion about
this Rook to B5 move it is quite
beautiful because a white white wouldn't
really gain anything by taking this
Knight and then the Knight gets attacked
and you don't really have a square for
the night and even if you play B3 then
The Rook comes to H5 and then you you're
already playing a completely different
game black would have a lot of attacking
potential here so instead Bishop to E6
but nipple just plays Rook D1 he says
take my Bishop here and he would very
much enjoy dividing captured his Bishop
because for the moment this Knight has
no squares but if you capture and sort
of Ruin white spawn structure then he
will play B3 put a knight on B2 and then
the Knight finds a very nice Square on
D3 so that's why after Rook D1 just A5
ding ignores the bishop Queen to F3 and
now Rook to B7 and only now after The
Rook came to B7 does nepo go for Pawn to
E5 as now the C6 Pawn is weak The Rook
on B7 is undefended so good things could
happen and here we have Knight the D5
just going after that Bishop here you
could also Play Bishop D5 and then it's
sort of a force line Bishop captures
Knight captures an after G3 let's say F5
now we could trade everything here
captures captures captures and captures
and B3 and okay it's perfectly fine
uh you could play it but ding goes
Knight to D5 instead keeps it a bit more
complicated he captures the bishop
captures with Bishop captures Queen
captures and now Queen to E4 uh now uh
of course uh moving the F Pawn is
impossible the bishop would just hang
here so Knights the F4 ding just offers
the trade everything here we have Queen
to E5 Queen captures and E5 Rook
captures an E5 Bishop captures on C4 and
now D captures on C4 and now we have
Rook the B4 biding uh the problem is if
you play D3 while playable it's not all
that great G3 and how do you how do you
defend now you have to play an ig6
attack the rook and The Rook captures on
A5 you will play D captures and C2 but
then comes Rook to C1 and the pawn of
course will be uh captured and the
nipple will just be up upon so here Rook
the B4 instead by ding now comes Rook to
C5 defending on C4 and only Now Pawn to
D3 and here you would be uh well you
could very easily be tricked if you play
G3 now then there is this spectacular
line that link had in mind of Rook
captures on A4 that was the true poison
of the position and after captures Pawn
to D2 and now after you stop promotion
with Rook day one there's this uh well
brilliant Knight A2 check uh King F1 and
down Knight the C1 stopping the roof
from guarding D1 the D1 uh Pawn is
coming next and of course this is
impossible as the D5 Pawn is protected
and the E2 square and the E1 Square are
protected so the white king cannot come
closer so they would this would be a big
mistake for nepo but he plays C captures
on the three Knight captures and now
Rook captures in C6 so just trading out
down in a very simple End Game Night day
5 attacks The Rook Rook C7
and Knight captures on C4 we have Knight
to C5 and Knight captures on B2 now it's
ding who's up upon but Nepal shows that
it doesn't matter Knight to E7 and now
you cannot defend If you defend uh
nipple will just capture it because if
you capture back then you just get
checkmated so instead after this Knight
the D7 move Rook the E8 was played and
now nipple just wins back the pawn so
now it's equal material nothing in the
position it's only a matter of how
players decide to draw this uh Knight to
D3 Rook G5 Rook F4 F3 stopping any uh
counter play here with Rook G5 okay
there were some tricks of Knight to F6
so that's why Rook to F4 was played H6
Rook to D5 Knight to B4 and now Rook to
D6 we have Rook to F5 Rook to B7 Rook to
D5 offering a trade and apple still
keeps a little bit of pressure Rook to
d8 and Knight to the F6 check now this
is the uh the little trick in the end
sort of ruining the spawn structure but
of course equal material of course it's
a draw captures on F6 captures on B4
Rook the D4 now now the Rooks get traded
off here we have a nice King H2 King G7
and the players will now once move 40
has been reached just repeat moves with
a couple of uh you know Ruby two Rook to
D4 moves and after uh 47th move Rook to
D4 it was in this position that Ding and
nepo agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here so second
rapid game ends in the draw we'll see
what happens in game three will we have
a uh decisive game and then a complete
roller coaster in game four or we will
see a game three drawn and then who
knows what happens in game four or are
we really going to decide the World
Chess Championship match with a Blitz
game uh we'll we'll see what happens
crazy stuff happening here so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh see you fairly soon